Congrats to youtube user Jesse Collins
for being the next winner in the
infinity war art of the movie art book
giveaway along with the art book Jesse
will also get to choose either a copy of
infinity war Deadpool 2 or ant-man and
the wasp on blu-ray and we'll get some
special edition posters as well Jesse be
sure to email me in the email in my
description below for the rest of you I
will be doing a very special giveaway
for Christmas and the holidays and that
will start when the Avengers 4 trailer
drops so be sure to subscribe with
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date
ok so Wednesday trailer watch good news
nothing's changed the Avengers 4 trailer
is still reported to come out this
Friday at 9 a.m. there was a rumor going
around that the trailer got pushed back
again to show after spider-man far from
home drops reportedly this Saturday this
is not true so ignore that rumor the
Avengers 4 trailer is still reported to
come out this Friday at 9 a.m. we have
the Game Awards tomorrow on Thursday in
which everybody is anticipating a reveal
of the Avengers project game the
Avengers 4 trailer on Friday and then
the spider-man far from home trailer has
been reported to come out this Saturday
so a huge week for Marvel we already got
the Captain Marvel official full trailer
on Monday and these next few days are
going to be insane I promised you all I
would keep everybody up to date so this
is my report for the day nothing's
changed if I hear anything different of
course I will let you know ASAP so be
sure to subscribe to my channel with the
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date with everything relating to
the Avengers 4 trailer as always thank
you all so much for watching we'll fluff
[Music]